hey what's up my name's samuel ladies in
this video i want to talk about getting
money from a bank now i'm not talking
about
robbing banks i'm not talking about
going to making a cash withdrawal
i'm talking about getting money from a
bank that's not your money
it's the bank's money but you're getting
it as a loan and
a lot of people don't really understand
exactly how this works
and i think the most important thing
when you're looking to borrow money
whether it's personal loan or
or a business loan or whether it's a
loan for a house whether it's a loan for
your
house or a loan for one of your
investment houses you need to be
able to look at it from the banks or the
lender's perspective and i think this is
the most important thing
see a lot of people don't realize how
powerful
loans are and how how much actually if
you want to be a high net worth
individual you probably also need to be
a high debt worth individual
and to be high debt worth you need to be
able to get your hands
on bank's money and use it efficiently
so i hope this video is helpful if you
like my videos and if you like the idea
of getting
money from a bank that's not your money
do me a massive favor smash the like
button and then i'm going to talk
through the different types of loans so
personal loans a personal loan is very
simply when you go to a bank
and you say can i borrow 20 grand for a
wedding for a car
for a party and that's just a personal
loan
now you're going to get a personal loan
if the bank
thinks that you can afford to pay the
money back eventually
that's why they'll approve you of a
personal loan and
weirdly if you get if you go to a bank
and you say can i have 20 grand please
to get married they'll give you the
money
but if you say can have 20 grand please
to buy an investment property
they won't give you the money which is
kind of strange i've got my own
theories behind why that is i think that
it's because they um i think that the
society that we live in like people to
be in bad debt
because then they have to rely on jobs
they have to rely on the government and
it just keeps but that that's my opinion
but looking at it from the lender's
perspective
if you're going in and you're getting a
personal loan if you've got bad
credit if you've got no job if you've
got
no means to not only pay the money back
but to even pay the interest payment
they're not going to want to give you
the money
and on top of that if you've got no
assets if you don't own anything
because if they give you 20 grand as a
loan but they know that you've got
your own home you're in a job your
wife's got a job and
nothing are you know what even if they
it has to kill them to pay the interest
we'll get it because if we don't get it
we'll go after them
for their house or whatever so they'll
give you the loan
you'll be a guarantor to the loan you'll
have to pay it back and that's that's a
personal loan i don't like personal
loans for those reasons
i think if you can't afford something
then just
don't get it you might be like i thought
samuel loved
debt different kind of debt so the next
kind of debt
is which is very very similar is a
residential
mortgage that is effectively
the same thing in a way as getting a
loan for
a wedding because if you're getting a
loan out for a house to live in
you're gonna have to pay that money back
you're gonna have to pay that money back
at some point
and how you're gonna pay back you're not
going to be able to rent the house out
you're not going to
so this is why i rent where i live
because again getting a loan out which a
mortgage by the way is a loan
getting a loan out to buy a house to
live in the house
is just basically buying something you
can't afford it
it's buying something that's not going
to give you any money back it's a
liability
so that's why they're so strict
on on mortgages if you're trying to get
a residential mortgage to live in
you need to prove so much they're going
to look at how much you earn
they're going to ask you how much you
spend they're going to ask you
if you've got any dependables and how
much that costs they're going to want to
know
your age they're going to look at your
salary your earnings
and they're going to really really go
through you with fine tooth game to
check
that you can get the mortgage and the
reason is is because they know that if
you buy a house to live in and you can't
pay the mortgage back
it's going to be a pain now of course
they're going to take the house off you
but they're going really really really
pre-qualify you before you move into a
house to live in
so that's personal loans that's a
personal mortgage to live in
kind of sometimes tough to get if you
want to get that kind of loan probably
shouldn't
then you need to have a good credit and
you need to have a decent income coming
in the more
the higher your income the better your
credit the easier you're going to be
able to get that kind of debt
and what a lot of middle class people do
is they get wrapped up
in personal debt because
they think oh i've got a good income
i've got a good credit
wow i can i can get 50 grand a loan well
personally 50 grand and every time you
go into the bank they'll say would you
like a loan would you like a loan
they'll almost press you to get a loan
they'll charge you a really high
interest
you think i'll get it because i can
you'll get it and then you just have to
work harder on your job
and then that's what we call the rat
race and you know they say even if you
win the rat race you're still a rat
so that is personal loans then we've got
business loans
now business loan as if maybe you know
you see on dragon's den where they'll be
pitching
the the the dragons that's not a
business loan because
that's a dragon putting money investing
money into the business
that's more like a joint venture
agreement um a
business loan would be when you go to a
bank and you say hey could i have
50 000 pounds as a startup loan and you
give back a fixed return
just to get your business started now
business loans historically are really
tough to get because in the same way
as a personal loan the lender the bank
needs to be able to know that the
business is going to be able to pay back
the money the business needs to be
strong enough it needs to have
be tried and tested but the thing is if
the business is
tried and tested is making good money
you probably don't need the business
loan in the first place
it's like a catch 22. now at the moment
they are giving bounce-back loans uh and
and the interest on these is absolutely
next to nothing
so i would probably suggest if you can
if you have
a a company set up you can apply
for a bounce back loan i'd probably
suggest i'd highly suggest at least
exploring that option because i can't
remember the top my head exactly what
the interest is i've done videos about
this before
but i took one i took a bounce back loan
so that's a business loan
for your business and it might have
strings attached
obviously if it's a business loan you
need to use it for your business
you can't take a business loan and then
go and holiday with it because that's
not
what the purpose of the loan is that's a
business loan
and then it brings us onto a completely
different type of bank loans and type of
debt
and this is when you're borrowing money
for
to invest it into an asset
completely different if you're borrowing
money from a bank
to buy a buy to let property the
criteria
the whole everything about it is
different
why is it different because instead of
you taking that money out
for yourself you're taking that money
out
to invest it into something that's going
to give you back money and you're going
gonna use that money
for yourself this is actually good debt
difference between bad debt and good
debt
so the great thing is you might think
i'd never be able to get a loan out
to invest in property my credit's not
very good
my salary is not very good i'm too young
i'm too
old i'm too this unto that but actually
if it's a buy to let mortgage
if it's a loan for investment purposes
well think of it from the lender's
perspective
do they care about you not really what
do they care about
they care about the money's going to be
able to pay back to them so therefore
they care about
where the money is going so what they do
with buy delay is they'll look at the
investment so they'll say oh you want to
borrow 100 grand to buy a house to rent
out
okay what's the house okay let's have a
look at the house
how much will that ran out for and
they'll check it out
hmm what's the value of it what have you
got a good deal on the house
they're looking at the investment not
the person that they're investing into
this is really good news by the way
because sometimes people say to me they
say samuel when when are the banks don't
stop giving you money to buy properties
and but
to buy houses you know is there only so
many mortgages that you can get
is there only so much that you can
borrow and the answer is not really no
there's not
you can borrow millions and millions and
millions and millions of pounds
but it's not personal debt
it's debt to invest it's good debt
so if you want to be able to start
getting uh buy to let mortgages
sure if you've got decent credit it
helps
you know if you've got a salary but i
know people that have got a 5 000 pound
salary
they make five grand a year and they're
getting by to let mortgages no problem
it also helps a little bit if you own a
residential property that is an
advantage to owning a residential
property because
they think oh well you've got a bit of
experience in property for some reason
but i didn't have a residential mortgage
i started in buy to let and i've now got
a
very very i have millions and millions
of pounds worth of debt
but it's good debt not bad debt so i
just thought i'd give because i get so
many questions about
uh debt about personal loans about how
to get money from a bank i thought i'd
give a little bit of an overview of the
different types of loans available
uh if you've got questions feel free to
comment them below and i'll do my best
to answer if you found this video
helpful smash the like button subscribe
i usually do property investment videos
on this channel and i do a video every
single day so do subscribe
and i look forward to seeing you on the
next video tomorrow thanks so much peace
[Music]
you